Thomas Jefferson's memoir notes on the
state of Virginia he he wrote that the
slave is incapable of love slave is
incapable of possessing and sustaining
complex emotion and that black people
are inferior to whites in both the
endowments of body and mind and and so
for me that's interesting because the
the man who's largely considered the
intellectual founding father of this
country who responsible and in large
part for the conception of the
Declaration of Independence in the
Constitution didn't think I was fully
human he didn't think that I was capable
of loving my mother didn't think I was
capable of loving my my sister my
brother and my partner didn't think I
was capable of having passion of
creating art and so there's you know an
entire history from the very inception
of this country of black people being
dehumanized by the state and people who
represent the state and and so that's
why I think it's important to have this
socio-historical context and
understanding so that when we see police
killing black men and women in the
streets we recognize that this isn't
sort of something happening out of
nowhere that this is actually consistent
with the narrative that has been you
know given about and to black people
throughout this country's history and so
part of what's what's happened now is
that we live in a hyper documented era
in which everything is being captured on
camera phones and videos and gone viral
and shared on different social media
platforms and a lot of people are saying
where did all this come from like how
can how are the police doing this like
why are they doing this this just
happened out of nowhere when actually
this has been happening for an
incredibly long time in black
communities we've been experiencing
disproportionate incarceration we've
been experiencing stop and frisk we've
been experiencing police brutality on an
ongoing basis for decades and decades
and centuries if we're being honest and
what's happened now is that now there's
sort of this these primary sources so to
speak these empirical evidence
of these events transpiring in America
and the world is being forced to like
look themselves in the mirror and reckon
with how so many of us had been
complicit and allowing such such a thing
to take place for so long and and to
really be forced to ask ourselves what
are we doing or what are we not doing to
allow this state-sanctioned violence
against black and brown bodies to
continue black children in this country
in part you know necessitate a different
way of means of parenting in the sense
that they it is important to inform a
black child of the realities that exist
around them without making that child
feel as if it is their fault right like
racism isn't a child's fault systemic
oppression isn't a child's fault at the
same time you have to teach that child
how to navigate a world that is often
taught to fear them you know my mother
and my father had ongoing conversations
with me throughout my childhood and my
adolescence and my teenagers and even
now as a young adult about understanding
the way that I was seen even if I wasn't
able to see that myself to recognize it
like when I went out with a group of my
white friends over and I if I'm in an
interracial relationship or if I am
engaged in certain activities that those
things are perceived differently because
I am a black man and that the the United
States and the world has a certain sort
of stereotype a caricature of who they
believe black meant to be and that there
are people judging me before I ever
opened my mouth right that there are
people who have who have decided who I
am before I've ever had an opportunity
to show them or to engage with them and
that this exists in every sort of realm
of class and I think that was an
important thing for my parents to teach
me as well as that you know I come from
a home of two parents with professional
degrees and and I attend Harvard
University where I'm getting my
doctorate and I think a lot of people
can operate under this assumption
they'll say Oh Clint you made it you've
transcended you know racism and you move
beyond these like
oppressive forces and obstacles that
have sought to keep you down and and the
reality is that that's not true reality
is that i still get followed around in
stores wearing my Harvard paraphernalia
the reality is that i still can't catch
a cab on Massachusetts Avenue the
realities that there are people who you
know white women will cross the street
when walking towards me on the sidewalk
it at nighttime and those things it
doesn't matter where I wear my pants it
doesn't matter you know how well I speak
or how smart I am or you know what my
house looks like because I'm black men
and and that is the first thing people
see and that is it immediately for them
triggers the implicit biases that that
I've been socialized to believe about
who we are and what we do or do not do I
think oftentimes it's easy for us to
exist in bubble and not to move beyond
our own reality and to step outside of
our shoes so to speak and and you know
walk around in someone else's and you
know that some people simply don't
interact with people beyond their own
demographic whether that's
socioeconomically racially culturally
and I think the only way that we can
understand what is taking place in other
people's lives is to listen and and I
was I grew up in a family where
listening was was the four most
important thing we were taught to do is
that you you have to humble yourself in
order to recognize that you don't know
as much as you think you know you know
and whether that's listening to my
grandfather at the dinner table as he
went on and on and on I loved him dearly
or whether that's listening to to a
classmate explain what a hijab is when I
didn't understand why someone would wear
a scarf over their head you know in
fourth grade and I think all of these we
have to be concerted and taking all of
these opportunities to to recognize that
our reality is not everyone else's
you